foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the break room everybody
it's our daily nerdy news show that
keeps you updated on everything you want
to know and this is a big nerdy news day
big day we've got a lot to talk about
today uh today's show is brought to you
by Pluto TV which offers hundreds of
free live channels and thousands of free
on-demand movies we thank Pluto TV uh
coming up today two big pieces of
gun-centric news today
Mr James gun
um first off we're serving guns two ways
that's right uh we got a trailer for The
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
it's coming out and just almost exactly
a month from today
um and James Gunn got a big old
promotion across town at DC that's right
um we're gonna get into both of those
pieces of news also hopefully we'll have
some time to get into some Henry Cavill
Superman news there's some black panther
phase five connections a couple other
things uh but with me here today to
discuss all of this and more we've got
Brandon Barrick I I can't believe that I
found out that I didn't get the DC
Studios job uh via deadline
great to be here don't forget to like
And subscribe guys please hit that like
button and please subscribe if you
haven't already I can't ask any nicer
than that that's actually accurate and
Jessica Clemens is here can't wait for
James Gunn to drop the bat girl movie oh
that's true he's got the keys watch him
have strategically play on this just so
he can be like okay no go take it Oh you
mean drop it like release it he's gonna
drop it again no he's gonna Drop It Like
It's Hot which means release it
he's gonna Back That Thing Up in honor
of uh guardians of galaxy holiday
special our Redemption today if we hit a
hundred dollars in super chats for every
hundred dollars we're gonna read a
letter to Santa
completely sincere believable honest
letters I forget some of my Santa Lord
does reading your letter out loud does
that make it not come true it's not a
birthday oh yeah I think you just can't
say you wish after blowing out the
candles I want to say I've pre-read some
of these letters as a as a as a dosat to
Santa somebody works in his inner circle
these are well worth it guys let's get
these letters red Tommy told me if I
can't write mine with pencil then he's
not gonna read it
if you sign your name with printer ink
or just from the computer center doesn't
read it you have to personally I wrote
my name in I don't want to spoil what it
says but you can see right here
that is my signature that's how I know
how to write that is not how you write
would chicken spray yeah okay uh and
again we'll get to that uh with one
every hundred dollars in Super Chat we
appreciate everybody in the chat right
now
um but first things first the big news
this just broke literally an hour ago
yeah we've been covering here for the
last few months the ongoing search for
who's going to lead DC's the DC EU DC
films at Warner Brothers Discovery they
just dumped officially Walter Hamada
though he'd been kind of dead man
walking for a little while they just
kind of officially fired him last week
um you know they were going after the
was named Peter Lynn I think was the guy
who had been a producer that they were
targeting who didn't seem like he was
interested and they snagged a big old
fish yeah they got James Gunn is going
to be in charge of a DC film studios and
we're going to talk a little bit about
what that means exactly he's gonna be
doing it along with Peter Safran not as
much of a household name but he
um has produced Shazam Aquaman uh The
Suicide Squad with James gunns these
guys are buddies uh oh actually what's
funny I'm sorry exact interrupt please
uh Peter Sanford actually began his
career in Hollywood as a manager and was
James Gunn's manager oh before directing
uh yeah directing writing but I think at
that point James even been like a Roman
acting role I'm talking like yeah 90s
when he was doing the trauma films and I
think that's why if you IMDb Peter
Safran he is this is just a little
inside baseball agents are not allowed
to have creative titles on Films
managers are allowed to be producers and
can even be co-writers on things so you
look at his IMDb and he's been attached
to almost everything James Gunn has done
because I believe at one point he's
getting a little 10 check hey yo what's
up no Peter zaffron's also done a lot of
non-james gun things
recently a lot of The Conjuring and the
nuns and a lot of um which is a billion
dollar friend yes I mean yeah no better
person to take than that guy that's been
just reaping that money he's also
incredibly prolific this guy does like
five movies a year producing yeah so
it's like if we want that DC train to
start uh chugging chugging he might be a
good guy to partner there
um so what does it mean that they're in
charge of DC Studios well we know what
it doesn't mean what does not fall under
their purview well we're kind of going
to talk about this tell me about like uh
the the Batman Matt Reeves Universe
right is gonna kind of still be on its
own a little bit they like it's not like
Peter or James Gunn can come in and be
like change all of this right uh give me
uh Superman in here like uh they'll like
work together but that's kind of
separate and then like the Joker Todd
Phillips Joker uh movie the sequel yeah
is still that's technically under Warner
Brothers you were saying right yeah so
basically how it lays out is DC films is
no more there's a clean Phoenix Rising
From the Ashes part in the Marvel pun uh
of DC Studios which is brilliant right
Marvel Studios DC Studios makes sense DC
Studios is in charge of all of the
Justice League sequels and kind of
whatever is grown out of the Snyder
verse and whatever's left in the wake of
that uh Todd Phillips Joker franchise is
they answer to Michael laduka
in Webster New York terrorized the
streets and claimed they had a gun uh
just one gun
15 of them but they had one guy and zero
bullets but uh anyway so so so anyhow so
so that's how that falls and then Matt
Reeves they have not made an official
announcement yet on his Batman Universe
whether it will fall under DC Studios
which I think personally makes the most
sense yeah bring it in under the family
let's have some real fun but I think the
problem is though if you do put it under
DC Studios everything that at Marvel
Studios releases is MCU Canon yes right
Kevin feige so if you do it under DC
Studios is the expectation I don't mean
to ask a question while answering
another question does that make Matt
Reeves as Batman in the DC EU with
Flashpoint coming up we know we're gonna
have some sort of Multiverse Soul uh
situation going on is there a chance
that they just kind of go like yes Matt
Reeves's Batman exists in the DC EU in
its own separate universe that will
never ever ever ever ever cross over
with Jason momoa's Aquaman I'm not
surprised by how much information you
retain but because you're in Hollywood
doing Hollywood things but you are the
leader of TMZ for us you know everything
I just read an article very recently
yeah
well that's because I love the word on
the street s
Tommy's a known ten percent
um well and I like that and this also
could just be they might not be looking
to have new Things Fall outside of it
but Matt Reeves and Todd Phillips both
their films very successful so they kind
of get grandfathered in those guys kind
of get licensed to keep doing their
things but what does fall under uh gun
and saffron's purview is animation yes
which that's I mean one thing that DC
has been doing very well very
consistently for the last 15 years is
all of the animations do not touch the
Harley Quinn show right I mean there's
no way they would that shows so yeah it
just got a Valentine's Day special James
Gunn is smart enough and that's right up
his alley center yeah he's on it so Doom
Patrol or is that I think they're on
there
I think it's their finals
Legends of tomorrow I believe is
canceled already well and I don't know I
don't know
either it's like the CW is like fully
separate I'm not sure about that one
well
and one thing we know is like Peter
Safran was already had already been
listed as a producer on both Shazam 2
Fury of the Gods and Aquaman too
um whether you how you feel about them
cinematically financially were big wins
huge wins made a ton of money and I
think are pretty beloved by fans yeah
Shazam specifically yeah I know and
Aquaman I you know I think it had pretty
good moments yeah and there was
definitely potential there there was
just so much in that first movie you had
like two different Villas yeah
um
what's going on here yeah but it's like
it's just a little puddle of due to
water so it's not like a lot of water I
don't think he swims with a dude hey the
ocean is
this is Dwayne The Rock Johnson's energy
drink and I saw it they had a black Adam
cross-promotion so I was like yeah
you're welcome that's a pretty tasty
flavor
um
what the Zach is it does re not reek but
like the abundance of peach I've
actually heard that that water is
changing the hierarchy of energy drinks
The Hollywood Reporter did lead their
article announcing the this hiring with
the hierarchy of the DC Universe has
changed that's a great lead all right I
want to point out and I never addressed
the chat Shazam
otherwise they wouldn't be making a
sequel
because you're a hater doesn't mean that
it bonded the Box okay so I suggest you
mail yourself a bomb and explosions okay
tell me okay trash bag
last thing before we move on and I think
this is uh this is exciting news for all
of us all of us enjoy James Gunn as a
filmmaker he's a distinctive successful
filmmaker we're going to talk more about
his other big franchise that had huge
news today in a moment
um but like I think I'm excited to see
what he's gonna do in DC like they
mentioned as part of this deal uh it's a
four-year deal obviously they could
extend that so it's like they're but
they're gonna have to hustle movies take
years to develop so like to get some
stuff out there they're gonna have to
start moving and um it still leaves room
for James Gunn to direct some so do we
get a The Suicide Squad too yeah I was I
was wondering that because he's not
gonna just like direct everything there
right he's still going to go find
directors and this feels like they're
swinging the pendulum from like the dark
Zack Snyder everything's very serious
heavy so like okay James Gunn is like
more light I mean obviously tons of
violence yeah uh and all that in his
movies but like a lighter tone more in
line kind of with like what Marvel has
done mixing like the action and the
comedy and stuff but it will be
interesting to see who he picks yeah for
some of these projects I honestly don't
know if they're gonna do another Suicide
Squad anytime soon if they didn't
probably be like an animated series or
something now that we have them I think
I like the show right and also we have
Peacemaker that's getting in second
season I think he's focusing more on
that and seeing and not in a way of like
I'm only solely gonna focus on this but
more how can I blow this out well and
the article states that he will be both
I know I love him
but Peter Peter will continue producing
individual projects in for DC Studios
and that James Young will continue to
direct the as I believe it refers to
this the occasional you will held on the
occasional film so in four years what
can we say he's gonna direct one movie
yeah yeah do you know if uh saffron can
do any other projects outside of the DC
I would imagine for Warner Brothers but
I think they're both exclusive to Warner
Brothers right now and exclusive to DC
so this is genuinely coming because of
now that uh uh Gardens of the galaxy has
done that's why the news dropped they're
like okay he's now done he's been saying
though for a while that he was done no
matter what yeah he wanted to tell the
complete story by volume three and we're
gonna talk more about uh the holiday
special trailer that just came out today
and actually why don't we talk about it
right now do you want to get in yeah we
got some we got some headlines from
Henry Cavill and black panther Chef
we'll come back to that if we have time
um no please uh but okay so the other
big news
um the trailer for The Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special we knew this was
coming but Marvel like with werewolf By
Night they've not been promoting these
holiday specials very much this was not
slated at Comic-Con no we didn't know
when it was coming yeah
um and so we figured come out this year
right right it was produced but there
wasn't a date given
um and it was kind of weird this trailer
kind of leaked today and then James Gunn
kind of tweeted it out so it was
official not a lot of fanfare around it
yeah which I think producer John was
saying that's what happened with the
Ant-Man trailer yesterday a little bit
was that it kind of leaked in a
different language and they're like well
I'll put it out so they did teased us
the day before yeah that it was coming
yeah I don't know uh but yeah this kind
of we we heard it it got leaked and then
we were wondering like how long they
might wait and then they just put it out
James Gunn actually tweeted it out first
uh but it's the holiday special we've
heard so much about another special
presentation much like uh werewolf by
night uh so let's go through some of the
frames in the trailer that kind of
grabbed our attention uh because this
kind of surprised me the look of this I
thought this was going to be more like a
variety show or something more in line
with traditional holiday specials but
like this was like almost uh a piece of
you know straight out of the Guardians
of the Galaxy story and James can even
said this is like part of the story it's
not separate yeah and just a quick oh
well that was our one of the first
images a quick reminder guardians of
galaxy vol 3 is going to be the second
Marvel movie next year it's coming out
May of 2023 so this is like uh a new
Boost yeah ahead of uh volume
I'm sorry what's the first one Ant-Man
and the WASP is coming out in February
and then this will follow like an
appetizer yeah I mean this is kind of
like a palette cleanser in between
courses right well Amusement uh prepares
your mouth to eat more so two people
have weddings they know they know what
these are uh I'll let moves any boosh oh
boy oh geez Louise what's your secret
the secret is I'm always horny we've
just had an HR meeting about this today
um so yeah sorry that first image we
were showing up there so we know some of
this movie is going to take place on
nowhere uh if you're not familiar with
nowhere it's the decapitated head of a
Celestial is this shot
you know uh Peter's looking kind of down
in his feelings he's depressed he's not
feeling good uh and we saw in the
trailer that like yeah they want to
cheer him up uh and they pointed out
that like they know it's Christmas on
Earth though I don't know how you know
it the universe if you're keeping track
of days on Earth I mean that's always
the thing that blows my mind in Sci-Fi
movies are like the calendars like we we
exist on a 24-hour clock and uh 365. but
that's all based on our sun like I don't
know anyways James Gunn has also made to
that this movie's gonna have its own
awesome mix and some original songs uh I
will say last year's like Hawkeye show
had so many good yeah Christmas and
holiday songs in it I'm hyped for what
might be in this one yeah especially an
original song we know they like to make
original songs uh they did that in
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 there was
one at the end we're gonna come back
we're gonna come back it was like an
original song uh so that'll be a lot of
fun uh and yeah like I said it's kind of
it's seen as an epilogue to phase four
this move so again the timing of this
wakanda forever is the final film right
of phase four and then this is coming
out right this has come out literally
two weeks after wakanda forever so this
is just kind of like the end credit
scene of phase four which is I think
this was kind of a cheeky thing James
Gunn said because they announced that
like black panther wakanda forever would
be the end of phase four and people are
like James good what does that make you
know your holiday special he's like ah
it's an epilogue
they don't ask me these things
um and yeah this movie's gonna tie into
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 because we
saw that they say in the trailer that
he's depressed about Gamora not being
around Gamora wasn't there Stella and
Thor love and thunder and it was implied
that he was kind of looking for her
remember this is a Gamora from 20 from
the past it was brought to the future
with Thanos because our original
Gomorrah died R.I.P uh she got she got
gotta vormir uh but uh this is like a
Gamora that was brought to the Future
that didn't have the experience of
falling in love with Peter Quill so he's
like depressed about that does this
movie start with the goats I don't know
if the goats will be do they pick up
where they left off yeah it will be
interesting to see where it fits in the
timeline and if if this is technically
before I mean we saw Groot is older than
he was in Thor 11 Thunder uh by look of
it he's definitely been Groot looking
Jacks he's getting some some hey yo look
at those look at those packs baby that's
too strong he's all barking no bite you
know what I'm talking about uh
uh one thing that really blew me away
was craglin's head uh we know he got
left with the fin that belonged to yondu
R.I.P the yondu uh his he was practicing
with the kid before yeah well before it
just stuck on his head now this thing is
like embedded into his skull that's so
great and I don't know if he was like
well I can't risk someone taking it
because we know what happens if someone
takes it but I was also wondering if
like he's been wearing it too much and
it may be like seared into his head and
he was like oh no
and your iPhone gets too high yeah it
brings a hole in your pants it's like
stabbed up and like scar I was like oh
that's that's intense that's got to be
hard too like sleeping with that thing I
think he sleeps like this a side sleeper
yeah I guess if you're a side sleeper
he's got like an inversion he's got a
boyfriend pillow or something I don't
know um so yeah
uh shots in this trailer of like there's
gonna be a Christmas party on uh nowhere
because like this shot with the Santa
Claus you can see it later in another
shot where they're clearly on nowhere
but there's a sign in the background
there that's in an alien language it
seems like oh they're gonna go to Earth
to get Christmas stuff to cheer up yeah
maybe the Reaver the reavers have stolen
some of this from Earth or something
like that they have no idea what
Christmas is out there in the universe
do they know it's Christmas time at all
we don't know we don't know uh there's a
new ship that we got to see that they
fly away in that's what they used to
jump through there it is the back of it
we tried to get a good side shot but
it's moving really quickly we don't know
whose ship this is
side ship maybe this was another piece
of a ravenger ship I don't know it's
hard to tell uh but this ship then comes
to Los Angeles very familiar with it
except we're based out of Winnipeg uh
and it lands on top of uh where the
Hollywood sign is uh you can't see it
there but it has like a cloaking ability
obviously smart uh now this is you know
I assume this is pretty present time
Marvel so I don't know if this this will
that'll also be interesting like where
in the MCU timeline this Falls is this
because we just went through winter 2024
into 2025 with like hot guy and
Spider-Man no way home and all that so
is this like supposed to be winter 2025
into 2026 or is this also happening at
the time of like no way home and you
don't have to Define is this before we
see the Guardians in love and thunder
we're presuming it has to uh if groot's
older if yeah because I don't know like
411 Thunder takes place well it does
look like Teenage Guru is probably just
taken some crazy sap drugs maybe he
didn't change that it has I genuinely
believe that it has to be after Thor
love and thunder but before She-Hulk and
before before she well it has to be it's
not during Hawkeye yeah because that was
the next year that's too far but it's it
could be Aftershock I don't know we'll
we'll figure it out if they're in Los
Angeles they could bump into Jennifer
Walters it's true that'd be so fun you
see someone dressed up as hers whatever
it is on the Disney plus timeline well
no that's wrong
I'm so mad about that I hate it it makes
me so upset I don't even know who to
complain to about it anymore sorry
there's a robot there's a robot
um this this little one I pulled a
little uh which images oh there they are
this is the boulevard that's Madame
tussos in the background if you're ever
in Los Angeles and you want to get uh uh
stabbed by someone dressed as Elmo this
is the place yeah very touristy area
they shot this in April of this year oh
okay they were out here in L.A shooting
these parts right we saw some photos
kind of that came out yeah yeah so this
is this is where they are they're
hanging around in Hollywood very fun
Walk of Fame terrible it's not a great
time real quick uh for folks that have
not been to Los Angeles Hollywood Walk
of Fame is is famous mostly it's an
awful tourist trap but there are these
yeah these costumed people I guess
there's some of these in Times Square
too but these costume people like your
Elmo a Jack Sparrow they like you take
photos with they then they harass you
for tips now
if we see an Iron Man yeah this could be
the perfect place right because like
Iron Man exists in the MCU and is a pop
culture figure so people could dress up
like Iron Man right we know that happens
right um we will not see a Batman uh
probably or a Wonder Woman
is this a James gun oh right you might
be able to like retro this was his job
application I could see him throwing
like or well he has to talk to someone
but talk to somebody but I feel like he
could put like a Harley Quinn in there I
mean now is like obviously a DC
character here and they're like who's
that guy oh Joe it's gonna be bad
we're gonna Circle back to other cameos
that might show up but like the
Hollywood Walk Fame also most famous for
it has like you know the hand imprints
and the the signatures of all these
famous people in built into the sidewalk
and human feces yeah I think what's
interesting about Hollywood Boulevard
like the Walk of Fame the Stars right
the actual stars that stretches all the
way from Hollywood down to Sunset
Boulevard through some of the worst
areas that exist in the United States of
America like some interests worse than
New Jersey nothing's worse than New
Jersey but I actually don't acknowledge
that as a state if you remember what I
named all 49 states there was no New
Jersey to me it's uh 49 uh 13 stars 13
or 49 stars 13 bars uh so anyway
12 bars I think New Jersey it was an
original colony that's a good point
bars we might be putting out a song so
anyway uh the area where the handprints
are is actually one of the it's
Hollywood in Highland is the
intersection it's one of the only
maintained and police air like like you
know police sounds like slightly
problematic but I mean like it's it's
made relatively safe for tourists the
exception is these costume characters
who roam free around there and you'll
get you say Jack Sparrow
it's sparrows plural you'll get five
Jack sparrows competing a couple Willy
Wonka a small person in a Chucky costume
several chunky Spider Boys yeah I like
the chunky spider my dentist is on the
Strip there and it's so funny because I
have to like park there yeah
some place to put a dental office
right at the corner by the mosaics are
in front of the TCL Chinese Theater is
it is I I I we we all have lived here
for a while so we we make fun of it it
is really a neat place I mean there are
hand prints like Charlie Chaplin's
hampers down there all the way through
like you have like yeah you get all like
the the entire uh Judy Garland's hands
were shaking when she put them in there
Mel Brooks is my favorite because he
added a sixth finger yeah it has six
fingers yeah they got R2D2 yeah three
Shirley temples little baby fingers yeah
I guess in just the slightest defense of
that very one specific stuff there but
you will immediately be put into a full
nelson headlock by an uh what I'll call
an Elmo because it's an ailing Elmo
please stop brushing my facts
here and right now I've got about 15.
real quick I do think like Jackson
mantis are two really fun characters
I've been walking down there because we
could see Drax is gonna take something
the wrong way and be like are these
people buried under these uh and also
mantis whose forehead is she gonna touch
yeah right it is interesting that he did
choose those two and not like nebula and
mantis or
past effective characters of this film
cost effective yeah also notes note that
Dave Batista is wearing a shirt yeah uh
something we almost never see drags do
again that's a lot less makeup you have
to apply to poor uh Dave's Body there
nipples but no fruit no rocket there
like you have to worry about all that
stuff uh yeah if we do a fantasy pick
for this my my pick is that one of them
puts their hands on the hand Prince yes
I can surprise it yeah I can see mantis
trying to read it and be like I can't
feel what they're feeling
math
um uh okay another image from this
trailer I pulled a little
uh bar they go to uh is it in the
background there on the neon sign uh
sign up where it says yarvos bar this is
not a real bar in Los Angeles but we
think this is named after this and you
would know I would know I've been to
every bar in Los Angeles
face down yeah we also do think this is
like an lgbtq bar because there's some
Flags there in the corner uh but uh we
think it's named after director David
yaravesky who uh he directed breitburn
fairly recently he's worked with James
Gunn on thing because he directed The
Guardians of the Galaxy Inferno music
video where you're talking about those
original movie uh music from the
Guardians of Galaxy movies he directed
that music video and he also has like a
special thanks shout out and Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 and in Suicide Squad
so I think uh David yaraveski has helped
James gun out on things maybe he was
like a second unit director or something
like that but I I think this is a little
nod to him this like yard I I I I know
you did great detective work there but
that's actually wrong oh yeah uh that
bar is named after my eyes doctor
yeah
he's my eyes down you'll go to your
doctor I like how you call him an eyes
doctor not an optometry no he's not
enough optometrist he harvests eyes and
then he'll he replaces
[Applause]
he is a doctor of what I'm not sure he
might be he might be have you seen any
like degrees any yeah I mean it's about
70 degrees in his office and he has a
degree from uh the University of Phoenix
and it just says uh uh uh I [ __ ] with
eyes
some people are eyes doctors some people
are used doctors some people are wheeze
doctors you know what I mean yeah so
anyway if you need new eyes you've got
to go to uh Garbo's okay uh yeah we do
think this move this special is gonna be
about like Christmas not necessarily
like a Christianity aspect of it just
like the Christmas part
very pregnant woman gives birth during
the special and says but I've never had
sex before yeah then they go truly your
child is this samanthus goes she's lying
she's lying uh I think Peter Quill will
will take the Eucharist in this in this
film we'll see they'll confirm that
Peter closely Catholic about this one
thing we were talking about we were
talking in the office so we do get we
just get some very brief clips of Rocket
and Groot in this they're not heavily
featured in the trailer so we don't know
how featured they'll be in the holiday
special uh how long werewolf by night
was about 50 minutes five hours just
under an hour so maybe we could expect
the same thing from this
um will we see at all Gamora in this I
don't think we'll see a picture yeah I
think we'll see a picture of good one uh
Peter Quill like looking at an image or
like looking at security footage because
he's trying to track her down or
something like that uh it seems like
we're going to be based on nowhere when
we're in space I don't think they're
gonna be flying around a lot we see
Cosmo in the trailer I love Cosmo can
you tell us just a little bit about it
Cosmo's an adorable little boy you might
remember he's the dog from the first one
there he is right there he uh in the
comics now Cosmo is like the head of
security at nowhere that's like his home
base uh and I haven't established that
yet in the MCU I'm hoping that's where
we get with this because you see like
rocket him interacting now also in the
comics Cosmo has like telepathic powers
and can like speak to people that way uh
I hope they establish that too because
I've been waiting for that I think it'd
be a lot of fun if you've played the the
Guardians of the Galaxy video game that
came out last year you're very familiar
with Cosmo's abilities he's like super
powerful uh and they haven't really
established that yet but why would the
collector have them if not yeah for the
reasons maybe I I want to go back to the
Gomorrah question because I realized
that probably Guardians 3 will be
heavily uh will heavily involve them
searching for this other Gamora and
trying to get her but there's a chance
and where there's a chance I'd have to
pull on that threat a little bit what if
rocket and nebula are going to look for
Gamora to cheer Peter Quill
and at the end after they come back
maybe it's a hilarious scene on nowhere
with Kevin Bacon and some assorted other
people we'll talk about that a little
bit later uh at the end they bring
Gamora in now I don't think that'll
happen because this is a special present
well I gotta say though Tommy doesn't
that make a lot of sense doesn't the
Gamora and Drax Thing feel like a b plot
yeah not an a plot right like you send
your goofy you send Kramer and George
you have to do this sorry mantis and and
drags off to do that whereas maybe the a
plot is they're hiding that they're not
giving that away in this first trailer
there is a bigger plot and I mean boy
getting Gamora on board so that at the
start of volume three we got our full
gang together yeah there was that I will
say in their defense the the plot
details that have come out about volume
3 are it's going to be centered around
rocket
um who's the female rocket character
um from the that's also a high
evolutionary uh she's like an otter yeah
um right and him going back dealing with
the high evolutionary out of warlock
there's a lot else that's going to go on
so like if a big part of volume 3 is
dedicated to finding Gamora uh where
maybe we wouldn't have time to get to
all those yeah you're right maybe we
don't have time maybe because maybe the
whole point of making the holiday
special was just to bring Gamora back
into the fold and then they just made
this fun thing around it would be wild
if there's some like big connections
here I mean James Gunn has kind of
tipped his hand that it's going to be
very important so I mean why wouldn't
you say hey if you've watched a Hallmark
holiday special okay how do they end you
know the guy and the girl usually it's
usually heteronormative at the castle or
the country house or whatever together
or at the mayor's the main Town Hall yes
she's just finished trimming the tree
that has been a tradition ever since her
yes she was little but her father died
this year so she needs another didn't
think she'd make it home for the
holidays but she did right it ends it
ends we thought you were engaged to
Samantha Samantha turned tail and headed
out of town 20 minutes ago and now I'm
ready to move on to you immediately but
Derek you work in New York City as in
accountant
that's right but I'm willing to move
here and start that General Store we
always dreamed of maybe make little clay
pots maybe make bongs I've been working
on a meth recipe
playing at the Acme theater on
Lankershim in North Hollywood all winter
uh I'm wondering if they're gonna
establish Santa Claus as like uh MCU
character like how does this movie not
have Santa right okay that's like that's
a staple of holiday specials even like
sitcoms being like uh oh hahaha where
did this present come from wink like so
many things have established Santa as
real canon in their Universe okay and
gotta do it and obviously this was the
thumbnail of this video we were teasing
that we were gonna have Santa talk and
Brandon's actually done some fun
research we're gonna come back to Santa
real quick we want to thank the people
that helped us to you Brandon's got some
really good uh uh Santa snacks to to
provide to go back to that Santa stuff
but before that I want to thank some
someone who's been trimming my trees
delightfully I want to think butcherbox
for sponsoring today's break room yes
finding delicious protein Pack Meat is
important to me believe it or not this
body's fueled on meat the grocery store
has a lot of options but I'll tell you I
get so confused there and I don't know
what the heck I'm actually getting I'll
buy the ground chicken and I'll read it
pump full of steroids my chicken's got
more steroids and Stallone so the salsa
King butcher box simplifies that for me
with butcher box I get peace of mind
when it comes to buying meat butcher box
takes the guesswork out of finding high
quality Meat and seafood that I can
trust 100 grass-fed beef sound good free
range organic chickens just skipping
around there living a happy life pork
raised crate free you put the pork in a
crate you lose me as a customer wild
caught seafood and it's always humanely
raised with no antibiotics or added
hormones get just what you want
delivered right to your doorstep or if
you're like me your Mansion steps free
shipping for the Continental us and no
surprise fees you're gonna surprise me
that's some other other box okay butcher
box no surprise fees choose from a
variety of box plan options from curated
and customized and change your plan
whenever you want you want more pork
chops one time they'll do it for you you
want all bacon I don't recommend it
magically but they'll do it for you it
might never any quest to eat better and
save money butcherbox is my new teammate
and we are launching deep bombs down the
field Josh Allen to Gabe Davis that's
six baby Tyler backs tax on the extra
point butcher boxing back told it's a
winning team and the main course for
Thanksgiving dinner can sometimes be a
main source of stress not anymore my
friends butcher box is offering our
listens listeners a free turkey gobble
gobble with their first order you sign
up today at butcherbox.com break room
you use the code break room very
important to get that turkey you get a
you're gonna get one 10 to 14 pound
turkey now if you're good it'll be 14
pounds with your nastiness okay I think
the turkey way
you'll never make it to the field of
reads listen to me if a turkey doesn't
balance with your soul I I weigh all
things I know people are imperfect you
want that turkey you use the code break
room free of your first box that's
butcherbox.com break room use the code
break room to claim this deal baby you
gotta do it if you haven't liked and
subscribed yet hit that button now I'm
not going to ask again where to work
very close to reading a letter from
Santa but we got one more spot to get
there yes Pluto TV thank you for
sponsoring the break room all week in
our house of the Dragons finale
breakdown in specific I don't know I
can't follow the red line anymore I feel
like he does this on purpose Pluto tv
offers hundreds of free live channels
and thousands of free on-demand movies
so thank you Tom that's what we got for
that don't forget to hit the super chats
we worked hard on these letters and we
want Santa to hear them if Santa doesn't
come to my house and say I'm gonna be
pissed and by the way like I said you
like And subscribe listen to Daddy you
like And subscribe now here here for the
cookies Justin in the Super Chat asking
do you think Santa will be confirmed as
a mutant parentheses Omega Level or not
in the holiday special and that's
indicative of the reams of research I
have done yes uh I used uh if you're
familiar with fandom they make a lot of
cool wikis they have a great one for
Marvel we use it all the time around
here
yeah absolutely I gotta highlight use
for it so Santa Claus does exist in the
MCU uh or in in Marvel Comics I
apologize he exists isn't Marvel he's
like a real character uh he's basically
I love this he's like a tulpa where like
enough there were three figures in
history uh Saint Nicholas uh someone in
like old England British elders and then
also Odin who did different things in
history that enough humans believed that
it was this like mythical force that
brings Goodwill to people that Santa was
basically formed from everyone's belief
in him uh and then Santa exists in the
MCU are in Marvel he's showing up a
couple times he has shown up like with
the X-Men where cerebro on December 24th
detected like the strongest mute never
Rockefeller
he was kidnapped once because he was
hanging out with Captain Marvel Yeah by
Jack Skellington we've seen a whole
doctor no no this is different okay he
hung out with Howard the Duck on several
occasions okay uh Spider-Man ran into
him once wow uh when he was chasing that
we beat that went on the roof which I
think all this is super applicable to
the holiday special because like often
when Marvel Comics want to get a little
silly yeah I want to get a little meta
when they're they're doing an issue
around Christmas they will include Santa
Claus as a character a mutant or
whatever and like doesn't that feel like
what James Gunn is doing with this
holiday special getting a little silly a
little better yeah also there was there
was a great story where like one year uh
no presents were delivered on Christmas
and so a group of kids got together and
hired Deadpool to kill
Santa's in the chat if you love Santa
guys I love Santa so much yes what if
they kidnapped Tim Allen thinking that
he's Santa but it's Tim Allen the actor
like if we're just going to act or heavy
because we know the Santa Claus the
series is coming out soon right yeah
that's a great device right there could
be a weird crossover in Disney Parklands
to have Tim Allen's the Santa Claus show
up as is there a chance Drax in and uh
uh mantis go to the Disney Studio
right and like walk into the filming of
a series yeah and they said they see Tim
Allen like taking off the the face late
taxes
he's a scroll uh I hope they go first of
all loving the Santa So Many Santas I
hope they go to the Beverly Center and
they kidnap a hunky sandwich oh I don't
think they do that anymore but there was
a while where the Beverly Center is a
very fancy Shopping Center in Hollywood
or I guess it's like what West West
Hollywood yeah uh they used to have
Billboards all over town with like
muscle-bound gray-haired men in like
Santa Hanson they'd be like you in like
cougars ice cream sugar acceptable
that's probably a problematic fan older
women that were still sexually active
would go and sit on hunky Santa's lap it
wasn't for the kids what about young
women are they allowed
I think some men said I think yeah I'm
certainly men were involved guys it was
a different time it was 2018. Stacey C
wants to see Mark Hamill as Santa
a good Sandy car well we should bring
Santa
can we get him Mark Hamill on the show
anybody anybody can portray a realistic
only authentic looking sanders no
offense to skinny people or young people
or whatever we want an old guy with a
real beer anyone else pissed off at Jon
Hamm playing Santa in those World Cup
commercials it feels like Stolen Valor
to me I don't support it oh though you
know who is a younger guy I wouldn't
mind uh David Harbor
deadly night
David Harbor with a gut you know what I
mean I've never seen the John Hamm and
he embodies the ethos he might only be
in his early 40s but he's got the ethos
Mad Men in his Peak because they were
trying to go from that body of like I
only smoke cigarettes
does ham have a gut can the chat confirm
that yeah
delete that for this month
let's offline about that be very careful
Google image searching John Hamm that's
always you search Jon Hamm sausage it
will show you uh what I can only refer
to
[Applause]
um
Dear Santa hi I'm Jessica Clemens I'm a
grown woman asking you again for money I
need money money will make me happy I
don't really need toys unless it's the
toys for other stuff oh honestly even
then I don't really want them because
where would you get them also what do
you expect me to do open it in front of
my family would I be considered a bad
girl if I didn't open it do you actually
use the words naughty and nice isn't
that weirdly sexual I mean it is I don't
know why I need to even talk to you
about that either way hook me up with
some money cookies honestly I'll take
some gift cards I'm running low need to
stock up on a Chipotle one sounds good
at first until your butthole explodes
regardless you do a lot of work and I
would love for you to be in my house
throwing some presents under the tree
peace and love Santa's biggest helper
Jessica I like that that was written in
your stream of conscious voice yeah that
sounds like our conversation you're just
saying am I a bad girl Senate here
chilling myself uh thank you to Stacy C
Cory Ken Julie Alice here for the
cookies Quentin everybody that
contributed to that uh today yeah if you
want to hear Zach Brandon's or my
letters to Santa don't worry we still
got them we just you know so if Santa is
in the chat uh send me a gift card to
Taco Bell instead of Chipotle I eat Taco
Bell okay do you have your cash app
linked to your Twitter account or
something I don't know you guys were you
saying Chipotle to try and sound more
sophisticated no no
yeah Zach Huddleston
um it's time for mandatory fun
pretty fun uh this is the segment the
worldwide famous where I gather my three
best friends in the whole world and I
force them to have a little fun with me
you know like the world is so full of uh
the night is full of uh Terrors and
whatever whatever that that quote is uh
the forest is dangerous do not venture
out don't don't go into the more stay on
the main roads into the woods into the
woods to have a child anyway my point
being this is time for us to have a
little bit of fun together now last week
we fumbled the bag a bit
um and or predictions I don't even know
if that's the right way to say it I'm
trying to learn how to speak like cool
teams we were we were simps quite
basically we didn't do and or
predictions I was still reeling from my
character being the only one surviving
putting me in a deep deep deficit so do
we have the dice
we are going back oh my God I want that
chair do you like my dress I love your
dress you look beautiful today as always
it's my Christmas chat pointed it out
too not shocking Alice 2746 Super Chat
thing I need more High rants from
Jessica yeah
I don't smoke I told you guys oh my God
yeah you snore you don't smoke no I
don't do any of the swords but also I
don't think you guys know that these are
my like these are my gamer dies I know
that Jessica and I only take powder uh
okay athletic greens powder yeah AG once
put your box a little bit of G fuel all
right we're gonna roll to draft
characters the four characters that I
have selected for and or here you go
Brandon uh brandor uh our Cheryl Karn my
favorite guy you love to hear the first
one and or size right guys please sorry
I got six all right Zach please wait to
roll this guy till I explain the segment
I'm like my children here that could not
help themselves the four characters we
will be drafting this week under the
normal fantasy rules of mealottic points
uh however I want our zero card and or
Mon mothma and Deidre Miro of course
head of the ISB or one of the ISB a
high-ranking isv office got promoted
with a permanent face like this
great makeup on her
she has the perfect face for an ISB
officer she does she's a perfect face
for an IBS officer stole your job
you guys keep stealing each other's
jokes the Great Scott yesterday oh
that's fine that was that was a layup my
his was more of an actual joke go ahead
and roll Zach okay uh Brandon rolled a
one Jessica rolled a six I believe I
rolled up all right so Jessica you get
first pick
I feel like I have the two best picks
left because indoor the titular
character yeah uh he's gonna be active
but I actually think this might be a
great serial current episode homeboy is
at his lowest he's stuck with like the
world's birthday or whatever yes he's
got this awful like uh super futuristic
boring-ass day job uh stuck in
um the bad part of um uh what's the Adam
Scott super super super boring random
ass day job is my favorite Muse song
yeah what's what's Adam Scott
Severance Severance he's stuck in
Severance I mean he he meet right him
and Andrew are gonna have to have very
little play he's due for some come up is
what I'm saying and or also might be
stuck in jail this entire episode we
don't know he's on some false ass
charges uh free and or so um
zero cards zero cards my best so you
don't come and that gives me and the
chat the shocking pick of Andor for once
guys we're living high on the hog I
don't think he's gonna be in prison at
all I think it's a prison break and by
the way prison break's worth like a
hundred points
this is a two this is a two-hander uh
mandatory fund today oh yeah no all
right second segment of mandatory fun
yeah the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special trailer reveals a plot to bring
Kevin Bacon
megalomaniac
I thought we could each think of another
person to bring Peter in an effort to
keep his mind off Gamora yeah because we
see them going after Kevin yeah
referenced in the first yeah yes and the
impetus for the famous dance-off with
Ronan the Accuser played by Lee Pace God
is here bring him back that was so good
happily married on a farm right now yes
you're showing up and all see-through
top all six six of them just a giant
we'll probably signed down for six
seasons of the foundation but thankfully
I only had to do one oh Lee Pace
we love you Lee Pace come on the show
Lee Pace all right and by the way guys
come on let's get up to another letter
from Santa all right how about these
boys worked out on their letters as did
I let's get going so we were saying like
who who else it would be interesting for
them to try and grab for Peter probably
cheer him out we thought it'd be funny
if they run into the actor Kurt Russell
yeah they think it's ego again I think
that would be a great opportunity we'd
love to see that yeah I want to stop you
okay because you're already breaking the
rules of this mandatory fund which I
didn't explain
no no no it seemed like he wanted to
stop this is not a round table
discussion this is a pitch we're all
pitching one thing and then at the end
if we have a little time open it up to a
round table love it so everybody pitch
your best we're throwing Kurt Russell
out of there because he's already been
suggested by Brandon I didn't want to go
first or should I go well I've I've got
one I just want to throw out okay so
Peter Quill Brandon was doing this
research again for me he's been Manning
the fandom wikis uh for us Peter Quill
taken from Earth 1988 19 years ago 88.
so most of his references are based on
1988 or earlier or they're all all his
Earth references are from 1988. it's all
the Challenger blew up and then he had
to leave okay
um what was uh so I was I was looking
through what would have been the big
impactful films that would have you know
much like Footloose that would have had
a huge impact on a young Peter Quill you
know it was one of the top five movies
of 1987. what was it the first
Terminator whoa they're going after
Arnie okay
um he's not in the MCU Stallone's
already in the MCU uh Bruce Williams in
the DC Universe that iced meech that's
right uh but a lot of the other big 80s
action stars are unavailable uh sad to
say Bruce Willis not going to be making
an appearance uh Stallone's already in
the Guardians universe but Arnie perfect
right also Arnie and Dave Batista nose
to nose come on don't tell me you
wouldn't want to see it you know I I
think that's a great suggestion my
suggestion though I think someone that
age or gone or whose Earth reference
levels has remained in 1988 there is one
man who is basically a Celestial amongst
other men Stephen Spielberg
Steven Dorne
Spielberg we're all adults here we've
got E.T we've got you know odds are VHS
technology existed he's watched Jaws
yeah he's watched Close Encounters yes
he's watched The Goonies produced by
Steven Spielberg we forget about the
Productions yes that Steven Smith
he maybe even watched a few of those
really crappy interactive videos Star
Wars American Tail right we're at the
Ewok movies both amblin
Indiana Jones flicks where yeah Steven
Spielberg yeah yes there's so much
you're basically bringing him uh like a
in Universe Stan Lee right like a man
who's created so many characters that
would be beloved by a boy that age I say
you bring him Spielberg how could he not
be cheered up that's good it's a very
good one you should another Steve would
have been Stevie Wonder
um
that's not mine you can go okay I this
is my actual pick okay this is the name
we've heard already several times in the
MCU Whitney Houston uh not Whitney
Houston uh they're not gonna get Whitney
Houston unless they bring a shovel with
him stop
I'm leaving I'm walking right now you
better stop me from walking off this set
right I think what what's gonna cheer up
Peter Quill the most what he named his
ship after Alyssa Milano oh here we go
yep she's out there go get her hey the
the Dodgers are out of the playoffs
she's available you guys are acting like
he didn't just come for Whitney Houston
it's not my boss who died she died the
kid get her unless they get someone on
Hollywood Boulevard
she's the best Whitney Houston
impersonator I know
she's not cheap some people in the chat
have been saying we got Steven Seagal
from j-ride Emilia I saw a lot of David
Hasselhoff's too but he's already Cannon
well we it wasn't Hasselhoff it was ego
taking the form of half sure and I would
say Steven Seagal's uh Peak early 90s so
I don't know that he would have been his
ever president he was lying about his
background in Japan they're going
they're going to Hollywood not Moscow so
they're not gonna be able to get it mine
is kind of is kind of like a tooth oh
God it's kind of a twofer if you want to
go
I'll make a judgment but for Jessica she
could have too thanks baby I think we
should either take Tina Turner or Cyndi
Lauper oh very nice I think because
that's what I'm saying I think you can
also take both of them if you want
because I think in his sadness they're
gonna be like we brought you the person
that like he has broken hearts like she
starts singing a private dancer and
where it comes out
[Music]
well I gotta say a uh
kind of along those lines Pat Benatar
could perform live music would actually
be great for him because you know no
matter what even if you're like I don't
want to see Kevin Bacon oh let's see uh
Steven Spielberg is here
can't be with your best shot
I like that yeah grandfather clocks and
stop Watchers in the chat for that
seeing some Drew Barrymore's some fresh
prince
wait Fresh Prince just do you not know
Will Smith's name my fresh prince Drew
Barrymore would be like if you get the
chance go outside and dance in the rain
Peter and then you'd be like I want to
die even more yeah okay isn't Drew like
a
if you get an 80s musician who's still
got some pipes it can deliver even an
original song we know there's gonna be
some original songs in this like let Pat
Benatar both do Hit Me With Your Best
Shot or uh Love is a Battlefield and
then also do an original Christmas song
Love is about it it was a Christmas song
I only listen to it on Christmas I'm A
Private Dancer I'm under the tree
right
in your apartment once again Christmas
in L.A baby
um watch the channel I think uh you look
lovely today
we're going to rearrange your gears
Thomas
Eric bus already has his reaction to the
trailer out on the channel tomorrow
he'll have the full breakdown of the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
trailer
um keep an eye out for that we'll
probably be revisiting that we also we
didn't even get to Henry Cavill in Black
Panther news today because we had so
much to talk about we'll get to that
tomorrow you want to appreciate a letter
to Santa anyway I can't read it we did
get a lot of super chats today people
buy some nice ones I'm gonna pretend to
be Santa and I'll decide whether okay
okay
Dear Santa it's me Brandon I've been
very good this year and I'm only asking
for a few things if you have the time
number one I would like phase seven of
the MCU to start with the first film in
the Jubilee Trilogy
number two I never want to see another
Star Wars project take place on Tatooine
we're done we're done with Tatooine are
you sure but this lightsabers buried in
those no absolutely stop bearing your
lightsabers on Tatooine number three I
would like a lifelong membership to Club
33 at Disneyland oh yeah but I know it's
like a letter to Bob Chapin you make
this whistle
Disney's bought most of the stuff in my
life uh number three I would like the
Lego monorail set you never gave me as a
child I don't think I make it anymore
well you're Santa Claus Mickey elves
make it number five World Peace number
six Professor X's hover chair are you
paralyzed no well I don't like to walk
to the kitchen at all because I would
like to hover sometimes uh number seven
I would like uh yeah seven seven I would
like an annual subscription to butcher
box yeah you could get that one too at
butcherbox.com did you know use the use
the code break room and they all their
foods are hormones and antibiotic free
take the guesswork out of it
nice uh and finally Santa I would like
200 000 cash and a kilo of cocaine that
you could promise
no get out of here
also uh thank you to set a x y and TD
Jones I think they pushed us over the
what became freebies are now earned
these all right well I'll read mine then
delicious earned these I'll give you
everything I want oh thank you Santa
anytime okay uh Dear Santa yes thank you
for granting My Wish 25 years ago and
destroying my parents marriage
the past quarter Century of two
Christmases has not only been incredibly
lucrative but also allowed me to play on
the sympathy of other relatives for
additional gifts this year being
unprecedented times I had to think long
and hard about what to ask you for
please see my list below I would like to
go to Disneyland with Sydney Sweeney
little Mickey pretzel with cheese
dipping sauces lady in the [ __ ] Style
I want a trip to Italy and I want a
beautiful Rich Italian woman to mistake
me for the big boy mascot from the Bob's
Big Boy restaurants and ask for my hand
in marriage
I want the stranger things Ninja Turtle
mashup figures with doubles so I can
take one out of the box to play with my
guys I would like personal training
sessions from Dwayne Johnson I would
like to be casting a Marvel DC or Star
Wars project and finally please make my
parents get back together 25 years has
been long enough you sick bastard love
Tommy Tommy as a fellow child of divorce
can I tell you there's a there was an
actual movie that came out when I was a
kid I think it was called All I Want For
Christmas yeah it was about two kids
using Santa to get their parents back
together or something my dad took me to
see that yeah no he had to he had to be
like you know that can't happen right
right Dad I'm already off the Santa
Train I'm not gonna ask to put you two
back together this is very uh if if by
any chance there is anyone watching with
little children right now please uh turn
this video off or mute this or or or
skip to another video thank you for the
chat Johnny two three okay so when my
little brother was very young he is one
of the first year my parents were not
married he he was or maybe a couple
years later he was like I think Santa
isn't real the only way I will know if
Santa is real I have hidden a letter to
Santa in this house and only Santa will
know where to find it because it's
really well hidden and if he does what I
say on the letter I'll know Santa is
real and we were devastated because he's
the baby in our family by like four
years he's significantly younger you
burn the house down
so we were all terrified like oh my God
this poor kid is not only going through
a really tough time in his life he's
gonna lose his faith in Santa well your
boy
rip that house from stem to stern found
that letter and we're rude
from your Santa to your pants uh uh we
were afraid that it was going to be like
get Mom and Dad back together which
unfortunately if either of you are
watching you didn't really lay out a
realistic scenario for that to happen uh
now
what it said in actuality was my
brother's name is Robert he wanted the
letter R circled and put in his stocking
because he's a [ __ ] dumb 10 year old
so we did that he believed in San
Antonio he was 30.
anyway uh kids can watch again I just
didn't want dynamic
after my parents got divorced I noticed
Santa's handwriting changed at the two
houses and the gifts that's what I
really said something yeah mine just
said from Dad and there were tears all
over it's a it's a Christmas miracle
here at the break room uh again we want
to shout out Pluto tv offers hundreds of
free live channels and thousands of free
online movies
um some of those movies might even have
uh divorced parents and or holidays 50
of Christmas is in the divorce okay wow
you never get a second chance at a first
Christmas when your parents being
brutally in the morning he's brutally
divorced uh thank you to everybody we've
got so much to talk about for the whole
rest of the week come back and see us
tomorrow my one mine's very quick my
quick letter to Santa would be Santa
make Disney plus quit dropping [ __ ]
episodes at midnight Pacific like And
subscribe that's my wish my wish to real
Santa hey real Santa I know you're out
there like this video because your likes
are worth a million likes yes uh love
you guys have a great day later skaters
keep it Gucci to moochie
[Music]